good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this year's Tanner lectures at Yale
University host
Center I'm Gary Tomlinson the director
of the Whitney we're gathered of course
to hear from Wendy brown class of 1936
first chair professor of political
theory and philosophy at the University
of California Berkeley professor Brown
is unquestionably one of our most
important voices of analysis and
critique of that liberal neoliberal
economic rationality that has come to
dominate our modes of governance our
values and our democracies and her
achievement reaches much farther than
this in too many other areas of
political and social theory and activism
but I leave further introduction of
Professor Brown to my colleague Paul
north her talks today and tomorrow will
be politics and knowledge and nihilistic
times as you've seen on the poster today
politics tomorrow knowledge might ask
instead in my brief introduction here is
to outline the schedule of towner events
over the next two days and to say a few
words about the Tanners as an
institution first the schedule this
afternoon we hear the first of professor
Brown two lectures afterwards you're all
invited to a reception here at the
Whitney straight down the hall directly
behind you tomorrow again at 5 o'clock
professor Brown will present her second
lecture on knowledge after that there
will be a short question and answer
session and then on Thursday morning
finally at 10:30 we reconvene here for a
discussion among professor Brown
professor north and professor Katy
Lofton professor of religious studies
American Studies and divinity and the
acting dean of humanities here at Yale
at that session there will be additional
opportunity for questions from the
audience as to the Tanner lectures on
human values they were established by
the American scholar industrialist and
philanthropist
Obert Clark Tanner and his wife grace
Tanner for many years a professor at the
University of Utah and a scholar of the
New Testament educated at Harvard and
Stanford Tanner also founded in 1927
early in his adulthood a jewelry company
in Salt Lake City the company later
expanded into broad areas of human
resource consulting and employee
recognition programs and it is on this
base that the Tanner Foundation and
Overton grace Tanner's
tropic efforts were built these efforts
include today the Tanner lectures at
Yale and at a number of other
universities in the US the UK and beyond
the purpose Oh Burt Tanner and visited
for the Tanner lectures is to advance
and reflect upon scholarly and
scientific learning relating to human
values in creating the lectureships
professor Tanner knowingly left this
purview very broad he wrote and I quote
him I see these lectures simply as a
search for a better understanding of
human behavior and human values this
understanding may be pursued for its own
intrinsic worth but it may also
eventually have practical consequences
for the quality of personal and social
life at Yale the Tanner lectures are
selected by the president Peter salivate
in consultation with the director and
executive committee of the Whitney
humanities Center were very indebted to
Peter for his assistance in bringing
today's speaker to us appointment as a
Tanner lecture is in is a recognition of
uncommon achievement and outstanding
abilities in the area of human values
and studies and we are truly honored to
add Professor Brown to the list of
distinguished scholars and humanists
whom Yale has so honored last but not
least I am directed by Yale legal
counsel this is a symptom of the world
we live in to read the following
paragraph our events may be recorded or
live streamed or photographed for
educational archival or promotional
purposes including use in print on the
internet and in other forms of media all
attendees and participants or parents or
guardians of minors attending the event
agree by virtue of their attending the
event or otherwise participating in the
event it's a paragraph I wouldn't accept
from any Yale undergraduate but there is
a agree to the possibility of their
voices or likenesses being captured by
these means and used for such purposes
without compensation to them and they
hereby waive any related right of
privacy or publicity I'll probably read
I'll probably read that again tomorrow
but
you you would be surprised at the
stories about those who do want a
compensation now it is my pleasure at
any rate to welcome to the podium Paul
north professor of Germanic languages
and literature's at Yale to introduce
our speaker thank you
thanks Gary and to everyone who
participated in bringing Wendy Brown
here I'm speaking also in the name of my
colleague Katie Lofton who will join us
for a discussion on Thursday it's really
a privilege to welcome Wendy Brown to
Yale Wendy brown as you heard his class
of 1936 first chair in the Department of
Political Science at the University of
California Berkeley where she is also
affiliated with so many departments
I can't list them but definitely the
Department of rhetoric and the program
in jurisprudence and social policy in
the law school among others before
Berkeley she was professor of women's
studies legal studies in the history of
consciousness at UC Santa Cruz where she
moved after teaching at Williams College
and receiving her PhD at Princeton
everyone wants a piece of her time it
seems and she has given unstintingly on
guests professorships all over the world
which you can look up on her CV unless
I'm it's couch she's managed at the same
time to publish six monographs as we
call them and two collections of essays
along with articles book chapters and
guest lectures as numerous as the stars
in the sky if there is a room in the
good place for those of you who watch
cable for people who got the most
prestigious awards in this life she will
doubtless have the first seat in the
room but now on to the substance which I
realize I'm going to give a kind of
quick survey that looks kind of like the
guide to your cable channels but go and
watch the programs I advise you at one
point in his early critique of Hegel
Marx admits that Hegel got one thing
correct historical phenomena do have a
logic imminent to them and yet he says
Hegel is still wrong all historical
phenomena do not conform to one in the
same logic each major historical
phenomenon has its own logic and the
task of the critical theorist is to
describe the logic of a particular
complex Marx gave us the logic of
industrial capital professor Brown has
over the past five years or more given
us the logic of neoliberal capital along
with its ramifications for democratic
for the self-understanding of
individuals and groups around the planet
and now in the most recent book for the
very existence of a social sphere for
those of us who learned from Professor
Brown how to register the political and
social effects of quote unquote wounded
attachments in the book from 1995 states
of injury how to construe the
relationship of political thought to its
history in politics out of history from
2001 how to recognize the tensions in
the late 20th century security state in
Walled States waning sovereignty from
2010 the turn to studying what she
sometimes calls the neoliberal order of
reason could be seen as a plausible step
like marks and like marks favor with
whom she will debate and think over
these days with us but also like her
other MIT Denton dimension as Benjamin
called them her Co thinking people which
includes Marx and Foucault among others
professor Brown is not only a theorist
of political technologies she is one but
she also constantly returns to political
experience to life among the nets of
ideas and practices in architectures of
power she repeatedly asks what is it
like to live under this or that
political technology in this or that
situation what is it like to live for
instance under a politics associated
with manhood which she defines once as
the gesture of transcending above living
climbing to detached heights of Reason
power and free enterprise this is in her
first book manhood and politics from
1988 what is it like as a contemporary
political subject to tolerate and be
tolerated as she puts it in regulating
aversion from 2006 quote what kind of
political discourse with what social and
political effects is contemporary
tolerance talk in the United States one
of her sources for the experience of
politics is precisely this the
discourses that justify this or that
power arrangement another source is the
discourses effects what she calls once
in an offhand phrase which I love quote
a few small voices
these few small voices always speak up
in professor Browns discourse no matter
how much she's theorizing the big
machines of power and they have a lot to
say the small voices are always ready to
contest one or another discourse by
describing its effects on them the work
on neoliberalism's logic is no exception
in undoing the demos neoliberalism
stealth revolution which it could be
argued has engendered a whole set of
debates from 2015 she presents that
logic and its effects on diverse lives
caught within it most recently in the
ruins of neoliberalism the rise of
anti-democratic politics in the west
from 2019 tells a horror story on par
with Mary Shelley's Frankenstein on
which she's also written a misguided
monster a mode of economic reasoning
sneaks into the public sphere and
gradually over three or four decades in
Boldin's itself enough to make a series
of once unthinkable demands society must
be dismantled politics must be dethroned
the personal must take over from the
public and common and personal freedom
must under no circumstances be traded
for equality the last thing we noted
learn in the new book is that
neoliberalism special logic depends on
an extreme existential commitment it is
nihilistic it believes in its heart of
hearts there is no future for it and
this no way out mentality unleashes the
sublimated will in violent and
unpredictable ways one might not
immediately think that the recent street
taking in Chile Lebanon and Ecuador
counts as the contestation of this neo
ism which Brown says quote looks like
freedom but Shores up the domination of
the status quo but in part one tries to
believe that the recent uprisings may
well be her Tanner lectures this week
have a collective title to do with Niall
ISM politics and knowledge in Neolithic
times thinking with Max Weber and as
Gary said tonight she'll present one
called
politics please welcome Wendy Brown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for that was enormous ly
generous and interesting thank you Paul
and Katie for agreeing to be my
interlocutors this week thank you of
course to president solloway and Gary
Tomlinson for inviting me and Sandra who
may or may not be here who made my being
here possible with all the logistical
details without which we don't exist
because I have a back problem I'm
sitting at the lectern which is an
unusual thing to do but I trust you can
still sing and and that you can still
hear me
the honor of these lectures is great
living up to it difficult I take it
they're meant to be mature reflections
on fundamental things but such a posture
is inimicable inimical to the deeply
disorienting features of our times
there's the rise of ferociously
anti-democratic forces in settled but
also relatively newer liberal
democracies they're open affirmations of
autocrats supremacist and violent
exclusions there are the deep
corruptions of electoral systems from
within and without above and below from
the capture of politicians by dark money
to the capture of electorates by
trolling social and mainstream media to
the warping of elections by corporate
funding and foreign influence
there's the digital revolution
continuously revolutionising work
knowledge governing social relations
psyche soma subjectivity and bearing
along with its enhancements of human
capacities novel ways of estranging and
manipulating those capacities there's
the economic revolution that has
unleashed finance as a force more
powerful and less bound to human and
Planetary thriving
and even capitalist commodity production
there's the chaos of the interregnum
between the Westphalian system of
nation-states
and whatever is coming after a chaos
marked by the unprecedented boundary
trespass and policing of ideas people's
capital labor technologies violence and
goods and of course there's the
existential emergency posed by climate
change plummeting biodiversity and the
debris of a retrospectively reckless
century of production piling up unmet as
metabolizable in floating ocean islands
and earthly fields of waste this last
includes vast populations themselves
cast office waste one in eight of our
species the human species now live in
makeshift shanty towns slums or homeless
camps within and abutting cities across
the globe
without access to what we consider the
most basic civilizational elements how
to understand and plot possibility
within this novel present for me
paradoxically apprehending the new often
wrestle involves wrestling with earlier
thinkers who were struggling for a
cartography of their own time and that's
what I want to do with Max Weber in
these lectures of course there's irony
here neighbors often held responsible
for setting 20th century social science
knowledge on a dangerous course course
of worshipping foe objectivity and
ethical neutrality intense knowledge
specialization and in the object world
worshipping capitalism and state power
he's identified politically with intense
German nationalism anxious masculinism
and early attraction to ordoliberalism
it's easy to cast him as complicit if
not an architect of some of the more
sinister forces contouring our present
but there's more to Weber than this
especially in politics as a vocation
and Sciences vocation the two lectures
he delivered near the end of his life
approximately 100 years ago that are my
focus during these evenings weber was a
dark thinker this was not only a matter
of his temperament or times though each
was tim treacherous as important was his
unrivaled appreciation of certain logics
of modernity its signature rationalities
and forms of power its generation of
human machineries with unprecedented
capacities for domination its
simultaneous proliferation and
depreciation of values the inadequacy of
democracy to resist or transform these
developments and the enormous challenge
of cultivating responsible political
leadership amidst these powers in a
world he viewed as nearly choked by
destruction of the human spirit and
human freedom as well as forthrightly
dangerous Weber sought to craft
practices by which both scholars and
political actors might hold back the
dark with their work this is one reason
for turning to him now we need sober
thinkers who refuse to submit to the
lures of fatalism or apocalypticism pipe
dreams of total revolution or redemption
by the progress of reason yet aim to be
more than Bartleby's or foot soldiers
within current orders of knowledge and
politics a second reason for turning to
Weber today pertains to his
confrontation especially in the interwar
period with one of the deepest
intellectual and political crises of
liberal democracy in the West prior to
our own intellectually Weber took Marx
and Nietzsche to be the major influences
of his time and he sought to repel the
anti liberal critiques from the left and
the right that each inspired politically
Weber took liberalism to be endangered
by anti-democratic mass movements hard
nationalists vain politically
irresponsible down
gods and the appeal of bureaucratic
legal status him to solve all of this
technically she's fantasized by
academics and embraced by some
politicians now vapors response to the
crisis of his time was not to
rehabilitate the liberal statesman or
representative rather it was to
cultivate leaders as rulers investing
his hope and those who would honor the
rule of law and liberal limits on
government while carefully using their
power to build political futures that
could slip the constraints of
bureaucratic administration yet moved
beyond the imaginary of liberal
democracy if today we face both low-rise
versions of this on the right in both
Sonora Trump or bon-aire Diwan Modi and
others we still may want to ask about
this possibility on the left that is
whether we want to rescue or throw in
the towel on liberal democracy it seems
to me the left has become newly invested
in the question of leadership leadership
for large scale transformations that
exceed parliamentary tinkering but are
short of revolution this makes vapers
unblinking confrontation with the crisis
of liberal democracy in his time
especially in politics as a vocation
potentially illuminating for the one
that we face a hundred years anon a
third reason for thinking with Weber now
and the main one animating these
lectures pertains to his deep
confrontation with the predicaments of a
nihilistic epoch the problem with which
I concluded as Paul mentioned the most
recent book of written in the ruins of
neoliberalism but did not manage to plot
a way through the problem if Weber is
better known for his formalizations of
methods and ideal types folding
hermeneutics into objective studies of
social action his unique reformulations
of materialism to Center the values this
list includes his
effort to combat nihilistic effects in
both knowledge and politics this feature
of his thought is overtly signaled by
his frequent allusion to Tolstoy
conclusion that in modernity death and
hence life have lost meaning and his
allusions to dostoevsky's portrait of
the ethical irrationality of the world
hardly nihilism is most complex theorist
Nietzsche Heidegger Adorno Rorty Rosen
Pittman and others offer deeper
philosophical accounts Weber may still
be its most political he understands
nihilism
as conditioning contemporary political
life and at the same time identifies
politics as the vital platform for
nihilism overcoming its the domain and
his view to articulate and pursue what
he calls ultimate values or tellingly
God heads divine qualities detached from
a divinity in the aftermath of God's
death there are many ways to account for
the contemporary rise of anti-democratic
forces and opportunistic masters of
power politics drawing succor from them
in the West only one of these would
feature the political expression of
nihilism a plant that Nietzsche
predicted would take 200 years to bloom
from the grave of the gods and ideals
toppled by science and the Enlightenment
nihilism is manifest today as ubiquitous
moral chaos or disingenuous Ness but
also in assertions of power and desire
shorn of accountability to truth justice
consequences or Futurity nihilism is
revealed in the careless even Faust of
breaking of the social contract with
others and succeeding generation
the witan indifference to a fragile
planet and fragile democracies it
manifests as ubiquitous criminality
lying and dishonesty but also as mass
withdrawal into the trivial immediate
and personal nihilism is evident in the
purely strategic drape of traditional
morality over ambitions to re-secure
historical supremacist of race gender
and ownership it's inscribed in crafts
practices of reputation repair shifting
with the winds opportunism of even the
most self-serious public figures
nihilism arrests and unprecedented
popular indifference to consistency
accountability even veracity in
political leaders it appears in the
shrill epistemological standoff between
right and left the ferocious defense of
religion and tradition on the one side
reason and progress on the other with
neither giving quarter or avowing the
quicksand in which both flags are
planted and on which the battle is being
played out and this list is just limited
to its political expressions so the
question for those who want to draw the
earth democracy care for justice back
from the brink what profit
prospects are there for a politics that
would overcome dispel or work through
nihilism and how might knowledge
generating it curating it transmitting
it not only be protected from nihilistic
forces but employed for their overcoming
Weber confronted precisely these
questions especially in his two famous
vocation lectures the focus of mine this
week by nihilism I am NOT suggesting nor
was Weber that all value has disappeared
from the world or that life is widely
held to be without purpose or meaning
it's popular under
rather understood as a condition rather
than an attitude nihilism generates
distinct predicaments for meaning and
modernity on the one hand it's difficult
to find criteria for meaning and value
without appealing to discredited sources
religion tradition logic a discrediting
that makes such Appeals inevitably
reactionary shrill or defensive on the
other hand faith and progress is
revealed as a secularized version of the
Christian millennium and it's
empirically confounded by modernity
failure to deliver generalized peace
prosperity happiness or freedom when
appeals to origins and Tilos thus falter
change itself loses its compass as if in
Nietzsche's words we Unchained the Earth
from the Sun spinning without tether
this last lost ground for knowing what
to affirm and negate and this lost
temporality for a motion of history
strips both purpose and judgment naked
unbearably so there's more for Weber
science Bisson shaft all systematic and
transmissible academic knowledge not
just the hard sciences science undercuts
the basis of religion but not its
continued existence rather Weber argues
in a rational and rationalized world to
be religious he says matter-of-factly
requires a necessary sacrifice of the
intellect religion must reject science
on the most fundamental question of how
we know what we know
as problematic as science topples
religion from the throne of truth it
does not and cannot replace religions
meaning making power thus the science
changed the nature reach and
implications of truth with a capital T
science can unveil the mysteries of the
world the process Weber calls
disenchantment but it cannot
generate or rank value cost-benefit
analysis can even review what values may
be lost as others are pursued but it
cannot decide the question of what
matters or why it cannot answer
Tolstoy's what shall we do and how shall
we live moreover when cost-benefit
analysis pretends that it can do this as
happens with neoliberalism a new
threshold of nihilism is reached when
Weber anticipated generically without
knowing what its precise form would be
while science unmoored meaning from its
religious and moral foundations values
are also eroded according to him by the
spread of instrumental reason itself
enabled by freedom from ethical
constraint and gaining ground by virtue
of its sheer power in relation to other
modes of thought and action where means
and ends remain bound together that is
instrumental reason comes to be embodied
in giant human machineries built from it
and encasing us within their power in
vapers time these were bureaucratic
states and capitalism today obviously we
would add digital technologies and
finance
darker still more than merely
independent of value instrumental reason
bears an innate Tencent tendency to
destroy value it over overtakes ends
that it was designed to serve or it
converts ends themselves into means
ultimately destroying what Weber calls
substantive or value rationality with
instrumental rationality again finance
and digitalization are the latest
instances of what started as instruments
morphing into apparatuses of domination
beyond human control now so powerful
that they not only govern us but could
crash the planet into catastrophe
overnight in sum for Weber in modernity
on the one hand all meaning is revealed
as
eight not discovered and values are
undecidable and on the other hand
established meanings are relentlessly
unmade by forces of disenchantment and
rationalization the usurpation of myth
by science
the cannibalization of ends by means in
a world governed by instrumental
rationality this much is all familiar to
even the most beginning vapors reader
the problem of nihilism for Weber
however exceeds the value depleting
powers of disenchantment and
rationalization rather it rests in the
consequential intervals opened up
between knowledge politics and religion
and modernity especially the
opposition's developed between science
and religion politics and religion and
knowledge and politics in modernity
knowledge features the value neutrality
generative of objectivity politics
features value struggle combined with
steely-eyed appreciation that this
struggle comprises human rather than to
mine purposes and powers and religion
rebuffs both sets of assumptions to
affirm values derived from otherworldly
sources these parties between knowledge
politics and science
I'm sorry knowledge politics and
religion produce novel political effects
seen at once in the way that Weber
shapes the vocations for science and
politics in his two lectures drawing the
notion of vocation Bayreuth from the
Protestant imperative to serve God
through earthly practices Weber iterates
vocations for politics and science that
are not bound to god but God heads again
religious remainders after the divinity
is gone to avoid descending into raw
self gratification and the will to power
in these two domains vocation as Weber
crafts it
until near superhuman attainments of
post nihilus dispositions of
selflessness maturity and responsibility
at the same time isolating religion from
this and shaft and politics and
modernity strips religion itself of
accountability to truth or power thus
when the religious minded do not stay in
their quarter but attempt to exercise a
piste of illogical or practical power in
the political domain or the knowledge
domain the effect for Weber is a special
kind of corruption one he understands as
nihilistic to put the matter the other
way around paradoxically the only
responsible actor in a nihilistic age
the only one able to carry us beyond a
nihilistic condition is one who fully
confronts the predicaments posed for
meaning making
now if modernity is structured by
unbridgeable chasms between knowledge
and politics and between knowledge and
belief only those who can face those
chasms and who can craft their passions
and endeavors in an ethical relationship
to them are capable of being responsible
scholars and political actors for Weber
the absence of foundations for value
simultaneously reveals them as
inherently imbricated with power as
contestable and as available to critical
analysis even if they do not spring from
reason or refer to reason for legitimacy
these same features are what make values
essentially political and also make
politics the domain for struggling over
values more than only affected and
infected by nihilism which they are
Weber casts politics as the distinctive
venue for countering nihilism dangerous
potential inversion into indifference or
worse fatalism
cynicism narcissism unaccountable
deployments of power and violence in a
secular rationalized and nihilistic age
when religious and cultural Authority
have disintegrated politics acquires
unprecedented importance for the
articulation the justification
contestation and pursuit of values put
another way when in vapors understanding
nihilism is full-blown ultimate values
are at once politicized in a trivial way
but also enlarged as the ultimate stakes
of politics on the one hand ubiquitous
politicization of taste consumption diet
pastimes pleasures appearance family
form parenting practices lifestyle even
body type all of this the politicization
of all of these things is itself a
symptom of nihilism on the other hand
formal political life becomes a theater
of nihilism
it's where nihilism is played out in raw
form and it is a site for its potential
overcoming this paradox the political
sphere as ravaged by nihilism and as a
venue for overcoming it arises because
for Weber the political is
quintessentially partisan it is by
nature interested rather than objective
though not therefore purely subjective
or reducible to interest the
relentlessly partisan nature of
political life binds it to value
struggle and the inherently non
foundational character of value and
modernity binds it to politics as one
interpreter writes for Weber values came
to be the symbolic equivalent of
politics which is why he banishes them
from all knowledge production and
teaching but the reverse is also true
values are irreducible in politics and
cannot be extinguished
without extinguished
political life as such and that's the
threat that Weber saw and reducing
politics to administration or
technocracy or raw interest or power
play again then while politics is itself
saturated with nihilistic effects and
modernity
it also has unique potential for
annunciated mobilizing fighting over
ultimate human purposes after their
moral religious foundations have been
shattered by disenchantment and
rationalization at the same time since
the currency of politics is power and
its ultimate instrument according to
Weber is violence and since the essence
of politics is partisanship there can be
no political neutrality objectivity or
peace ever thus
value struggles are eternal cold comfort
for those still invested in narratives
of progress all right so that dizzying
thing I just told you is the capsule
version of my argument and for the next
half day and tomorrow I'm gonna wing it
out slowly the capsule version of my
argument okay
essentially offers you a sense of why I
think Labour's anti nihilistic
orientation to politics and knowledge
may have some use today favors account
of nihilism effects is informed by yet
varies from Nietzsche's for Nietzsche
nihilism devalues values including the
value of truth itself while keeping
values and truth around for Nietzsche
the foundation eroded values do not
vanish but rather become malleable
fungible trivial instrumental izybelle
easily trafficked for purposes beyond
themselves contemporary examples abound
in commerce politics religion and the
branding of everyone and everything
indeed when values become capital
enhancing as they are today for
individuals corporations schools
nonprofits cities and state
they're trivialization and
instrumentalization are complete but for
Nietzsche the devaluation of values also
entails a radical reduction in the force
of conscience the sublimation of
instincts or desires required by the
authority of values is when values are
devalued lightened even reversed the
erupted the result is antisocial
eruptions again examples are abundant
disinhibition including aggressive and
violent forms is increasingly routine in
the world today and accompanies
accompanies cynicism and contractual ISM
in the domain of values the conscience
at the heart of the Liberal Democratic
social conscious contract is also thrown
off obligations to fairness inclusion
the rule of law and future generations
becomes increasingly easy to violate or
suspend one more effect worth
underscoring in Nietzsche's account of
nihilistic symptoms before turning to
vapours is hyper individualism the
social contract with others and with
past and future now broken we fall into
a world of one a world of now again this
formation dovetails neatly with
neoliberal income eum's of the past
half-century nihilism both facilitates
the acceptability of neoliberal reason
and is intensified by it truth Nietzsche
argues is devalued along with every
other value in a nihilistic age more
than strategically overwhelmed by
propaganda fused with Commerce
manipulated by opportunistic demagogues
and Russian trolls truth in a nihilistic
condition like its cousins honesty
integrity and accountability cannot
survive the D grounding and diminution
of value so also does the sharp
opposition but
science and religion abet truths slide
if religion doesn't have truth then it
doesn't want it need it
admire it furnish it or protect it now
this condition still with Nietzsche
generates several possible formations
what Nietzsche calls the pale atheists
dwell in irony
skepticism and above all themselves
narcissism is a boom industry in a
nihilistic age with all value diminished
only immediate gratification and
security remain compelling in
Nietzsche's view and again comport
easily we would say today with the
governing rationality of both neoliberal
but also secure terian authoritarianism
for Nietzsche ardent religionists on the
other hand clutch their crosses and
refuse intellection today making them
easily available to mobilization by a
bull sonora or a trump both tendencies
narcissistic self-indulgence and
religion without depth Express what
Robert Pippin terms the failure of
desire that is nihilism it's lost want
of world it's lost want of the other or
even its own life now for Nietzsche
working through nihilism involves
culturing value at a deep and
nonreactive level and seeking to
instantiate it or legislate it in and
for the world importantly such
conviction for Nietzsche does not arise
from deliberation or choice but shares
the non-rational non-strategic character
of eros as Pippin puts it something
grips us something we can't help caring
about it would not be love if it were in
the service of some instrumental
strategy and far more than simply a felt
desire it involves a wholehearted
passionate commitment to and
identification with a desired end so for
Nietzsche overcoming nihilism does not
mean rationally deciding what to value
across a diverse order of objects and
possibilities which would in any case
heists that fix
that little changeling the subject the
doer behind the deed the neutral
substratum that is before willing but
rather it involves arriving at this
value the value of what to value
affirming some value in the world from a
wellspring of passionate attachment of
course this attachment can be shaped by
education or influence or experience and
we'll want to come back to this but that
passion is now at the root of value
means it's post nihilist version is
divorced not only from authority but
from cultural reproduction and
saturation from foundations that would
secure its truth but also from a
homogeneous culture everywhere
generating and reflecting it even if
widely accepted and successfully
legislated this novelty would remain so
the reversal of the origin of value in
late or post modernity from inculcation
by world to overt legislation by power
is one reason that Weber a very serious
student of Nietzsche will locate post
nihilist regeneration of value at the
site of charismatic leadership I haven't
said that favors account also diverges
from Nietzsche's for Weber disintegrated
foundations until less the weakening and
trivialization of values than their
proliferation and diversification the
authority that would secure a single and
common truth gone we now live he says as
the ancients did when they would quote
bring a sacrifice at one time to
Aphrodite and another to Apollo
only now the gods have been deprived of
the magical and mythical but inwardly
true qualities that gave them such vivid
immediacy and God favors invocation of
the Greeks here is laden with ultimate
values undecidable were returned to a
certain pre-modern pre-christian
addition and breaking of the
Enlightenment promise its dethroning
rather than crowning of truth in the
domain of value having lost its ground
and truth supported neither by science
nor capitalism
this makes liberalism and the values it
subtends deeply vulnerable
nothing guarantees liberalism survival
when as Weber puts it each individual
has to decide for himself which is the
devil in which the God for him
indeed as values proliferate and
diversify and vapors view peoples and
nations will inevitably be splintered
and riven not only facing the external
clashes of civilization rock today by
globalization but rather the kinds of
things that we offer through our
nomenclatures of culture wars extreme
political polarization though these
inadequately captured a historical
condition that weber charts for him the
lost foundation is primary and
fracturing values so things like neela
neoliberal deracinated
religious secular and rural urban
divides these only fertilize that
already strong ground deep divisions
generated by proliferating values are
one political expression of nihilism for
Weber destructive hyper political
cessation is another everything in a
nihilistic age becomes iconic of the
struggle over values again today these
include things like consumption
practices family forms home style and
decor gun ownership curriculums sports
ecological practices fashion sexuality
diet exercise and more at the same time
hyper politicization means that force
and fraud contaminate value everywhere
more than merely deployed for branding
moral values and knowledge itself are
instrumentalized for power
is law and religion to shed even the
pretense of non political status hence
the quotidian politicization for example
of Judicial Appointments interpretations
and decisions and Abids by megachurches
to throw off legal constraints on
political engagement these moves of
course in turn deepen skepticism about
truth deepen skepticism about the
integrity of faith and about the value
of law as a neutral arbiter and
protector and this in turn intensifies
the nihilistic downward war how then for
Weber does politics as struggle over
ultimate values counter nihilism how is
religious and moral authority Wayne and
politics itself is saturated with
nihilistic effects how might political
life be a stage for renewing value and
human integrity Faber's genius is to
dive right straight into the
predicaments of nihilism to insist that
political leadership take its bearings
and develop its ethics from the loss of
moral foundations and from the permanent
embrocation of all political purposes
with what he calls diabolical powers let
us turn to this work in the dismal
intentionally tedious first two thirds
of politics as a vocation weber details
the effects of rationalization in modern
politics its generation of bureaucratic
and administrative mentalities on the
one hand and its party machines with
their hacks and spoils on the other
there are also the stupid masses thirsty
for demagoguery who cannot appreciate
the complex internal and external
relations of modern States and thus for
Weber cannot be represented only
LED Weber crafts the ideal political
leader in relation to these conditions
but also as a mode of rising above them
and redeeming grander possibilities of
political life the political hero the
political leader or the political actor
as he designs it has a love of power but
is without vanity is committed to
realizing a political vision but in a
responsible non obsessional fashion is
charismatic yet restrained ethical
capable of withstanding endless setbacks
and disappointments without giving up
each of these is a retort to the
depredations of rationalization and of
nihilism each center's value and
dissenters ego and cheap spectacle this
also means there's nothing organic about
Faber's ideal politician it's not
eminent to the present conditions but
called from sources external to them
even as it has to be completely savvy
about them nor is this a calling from
God rather again
Weber gives us vocation secularized and
constructed a constructivism so obvious
he does not bother underlining it
arising neither from dialectics nor
eminence informed neither by social
science nor religion political
possibility against the darkness emerges
from a leader bearing the spirit force
and stamina to resist all features of a
nihilistic age with a passionate public
purpose
this is neighbors wager not a
revolutionary overthrow of the forces of
the present from which he feared only a
different
Machinery of domination but the singular
promise of political leadership that
could recenter the human capacity to
forge common life on the basis of that
capacity to determine what to value
what's the part of charisma though in
vapors project of overcoming nihilism in
politics here vapors not just
capitulating to contemporary demands for
demagoguery rather of the three kinds of
authority weber famously charts
charismatic traditional rational legal
charisma alone compels through a promise
of emancipation emancipation from the
givenness and the routines of the
present charisma attracts and especially
attracts its followers by leading
somewhere aspiring to something new and
in this counters the nihilistic
depression of value itself revolutionary
in a non Marxist sense charisma also
challenges the value depleting
characteristics of rational-legal
authority it promises to re intent as it
reforms the world yet in Faber's account
is distinguished from other
revolutionary modalities by balancing
what he calls inner determination inner
restraint much of its force arises from
this vital tension between determination
and restraint Rob determination by
itself easily becomes reckless ambition
restraint alone veers toward reluctance
or compromise
thus the charismatic that Weber depicts
in this essay combines what he calls
heated passion and a cool sense of
proportion to achieve again quoting a
trained ruthlessness towards one's own
cause what some have called political
contain ism and a distance to things and
men all of this passion for an
impersonal cause restraint determination
a sense of proportion the pathos of
distance challenge
Toodee sublimated aggressions the petty
preoccupations the rancorous ness
self-absorption and desire for immediate
satisfaction that nihilism generates
these qualities also oppose what weber
takes to be other political motifs of
the day administrative legalistic or
technocratic orientations sensibilities
he disparages as sterile excitement
those of the revolutionaries naive
idealism those of the purists and the
moralist and frivolous intellectual play
those of us in the academy more about
this in a moment
sober dogged responsible pursuit of an
impersonal cause of course is not
passions quotidian form especially but
not only in a nihilistic age rather the
bearing and the ethos that Weber depicts
requires routing passion away from its
natural course deferring are altogether
denying its gratifications
and coloring it with what he calls
habituation to detachment in every sense
of the word
so Weber has drawn a nearly impossible
figure a charismatic personality with a
strong instinct for power yet animated
exclusively by a worldly cause whose
daily work he refers to as slow boring
through hard boards struggling against
the established machineries of power and
who is restrained sober detached and
consummately responsible now before we
pursue this problem further we need to
ask why does Faber keep drawing on
responsibilities rather than reason as
political passions harnessing force in
an age dominated by instrumental
rationality Weber fears reason alone
adds only calculation to deliberation
and calculation combined with passion
would lead to the most dangerous of
political tendencies in which the end
justifies the means and every
from laws to constitutions to other
causes to humans
maybe instrumentalized for ones purposes
so not calculative reason but a
distinctive ethic of responsibility for
all effects of an action including
collateral and unintended ones is
required to guide without choking
political passion in addition to
avoiding instrumental ISM this ethic is
intended to curb vanity which Weber
considers among the most deadly forces
of contemporary political life for Weber
vanity stands for the moment when the
political power instinct so essential in
political actors overrides the cause to
which they are committed to become self
intoxication vanity signals
identification with rather than distance
from the course of history that one is
trying to shape and from the power that
one wields for that aim when a leader
becomes the cause rather than the vessel
for it
detachment restraint responsibility and
reflection fall away and the thrill of
power takes center stage vapor dwells at
length on this problem because he sees
vanity not merely as an attribute of
certain personalities but endemic in
politics especially when nihilism is in
full bloom when Weber says the demagogue
is forced to play for effect he always
runs the risk both of turning into an
actor and taking to lightly his
responsibility for his actions favours
judgment here is ferocious quote
although or rather because power is an
unavoidable tool of politics and the
striving for power therefore one of its
driving forces there is no more
destructive distortion of political
energy than when the parvenu Swagger's
around boasting of his power concededly
reveling in its reflected glory
Weber dams the quote impoverished and
superficial and DIF toward the mean
of human activity embodied in this pose
a pure expression of nihilism its lack
of commitment to anything other than
itself and its corresponding lack of
responsibility for its actions comprised
the two kinds of what he calls mortal
sins in the field of politics apart from
the problem of vanity Faber's argument
for a distinctive political ethic of
responsibility is conventionally read as
a response to the unpredictable effects
of action what he sometimes calls the
tragedy of action in a dynamic sphere
suffused with dialogue diabolical powers
including violence but it's also aimed
at contesting both rationalization and
nihilism the former swallowing of
freedom and greatness and the latter's
reduction of politics to exercising
power without right violence without
responsibility and instrumentalizing
hence erasing value bound to leadership
the ethic of responsibility aims to
recenter values and politics as their
province after secularism destroyed
their foundation after rationalism
destroyed their place and after nihilism
destroyed their depth and dignity it
aims to recover politics as the domain
of the struggle over ultimate values
without allowing values to become
religious dogma or pure weaponry it
seeks to embed values in a project of
overcoming nihilism both in individuals
and society writ large and it seeks to
reestablish responsibility in the
context of an ethically irrational order
in which what we have shaped is never
fully in our control each of these is a
post nihilist strategy discussion and
the ethic of responsibility comes near
the end of politics of a vocation but
it's set up early weber opens his
lecture by defining politics annoying
we narrowly as leadership of a political
organization and then he says in other
words a state and then he declares
curiously that the modern state may be
sociologically stipulated only with
reference to its peculiar means namely
its monopoly of political I'm sorry its
monopoly of physical violence
now Weber knows there's more two states
much of his essay is dedicated to their
emergence and consolidation their
apparatuses and institutions their
distinctive organization of political
life
so why define States in terms of
violence when even their distinctive
means includes law and bureaucracy in
part Weber is setting up his critiques
of socialism revolution and Christian
pacifism doctrine C believes
disingenuously and dangerously isolate
their virtues from their imbrication
with state violence Faber
consummate theorists of power of means
separated from ends and capitalism and
bureaucracy is also finely attuned to
the wreckage unleashed by political
causes
whenever ends are said to justify the
means
hence what he's trying to do with this
ethic is conceptually resuture the
ultimate modern political means state
violence to all political purposes or
ends he underscores the use of violence
and accidental unleashing of violence as
an inescapable feature of politics this
potential hovers over every political
act and event whether the aim is to lead
seize or smash the state to prevent
start join or start stop a war to
initiate reform or overturn a law again
weber centers violence and politics not
to affirm it as the essence of politics
it's only an instrument but instruments
are also never only for Weber this
master theorist of the capacity
means to swallow ends so he aims to
throw on their feet and take the chair
away from those who clutch their
principles or defend their actions and
politics without reference to this
instrument his strategy is to
continuously burden actors with
responsibility for both means and ends
while treating them as distinctive from
one another the same action or actor is
responsible for both and politics always
comprises both and spur weber neither
abstract principle nor raw calculation
nor realpolitik have a place in post
nihilist politics in formulating his
ethic of responsibility weber famously
contrasts it with two others one he
calls an absolute ethic found solely to
a moral code such as Christian virtue or
pacifism adherents of this ethic ignore
the tragedy of action that D linking of
motive aim and effect that for Weber
comprises the political realm the nature
of the political realm responsibility is
required because motive and effect are
deal aimed the absolute ethic or what he
sometimes calls an ethic of conviction
conviction disavows this part of
politics and often ends up weber says to
cry in a world too stupid or to base for
one's principles to govern thus does the
absolute ethic reveal itself as a form
of risk something more against politics
what may be calls an ethic of ultimate
ends refuses the ethical irrationality
of politics in a different way this
ethic is contoured by its commitment to
an end state some rational ideal one
imagined devoid of distortions by power
and partisanship and therefore justifies
any means to get there now vapors main
target here is Bolshevism but it's
noteworthy that the classical neoliberal
are also vulnerable to this charge they
imagine the power problem in politics
conquered by the spontaneous order of
markets and morals and justify a good
measure of state violence and other
collateral damage to bring into being
their idealized orders from Coos and
occupations to ordinary downsizing
offshoring and so forth absolute ethics
politicians reduce politics to
principles and ultimate ends politicians
reduce politics to a teleology of reason
for Weber both dangerously divided means
from ends and both ignore the specific
powers partisanship and tragedy of
action that are permanent features of
politics both shirk responsibility for
what becomes of what they stand for
moreover if each hyper personalizes the
ethical dimension of action referring
everything back to their personal motive
or aim they also radically
depersonalized
actions worldly effects treating
principle or reason as governing the
meaning of action and this too avoids
responsibility in politics where
intentions and ethics f effects so often
lay worlds apart and yet weber famously
concludes this discussion only one who
marries an ethic of conviction - an
ethic of responsibility has the true
calling for politics so how are they
twinned in a single set of practices a
single being Faber's vocabulary here
is telling maturity sobriety manly
fortitude restraint
ability to withstand disappointment and
setbacks without whining cynicism or
retreat the ability to persist despite
it all converting nature's complex
pathos of distance from a class-based
sensibility to a personal one distance
from self and things weber invokes
Luther's resolute here I stand I can do
no other - just to express the moment
when conviction reigns supreme
waiting is knowingness tolerance for
suffering in place of Nietzsche's gaiety
and laughter for overcoming nihilism
building not breaking things avoidance
of resentment vengeance even ordinary
face-saving avoiding all the reactive
and vain temptations above all the post
nihilist political actor is willing to
sacrifice self but not others to a
political cause steadfastly refusing
nihilistic reduction of everything to
individual interest power or security
this ethic of responsibility also
represents a path through nihilism in
its representation of ultimate value in
political life and by inhabiting a set
of difficult political epistemological
commitments to renew human freedom let
me turn to these briefly before
concluding to take one's own values as
true with a capital T and demonize all
others is already in vapers view to
inhabit something of the absolute ethic
that he criticizes conversely
recognizing political godheads as
beliefs rather than truths Foster's the
objectivism and sense of proportion that
he seeks for responsible political
action in a sphere that is partisan
all the way down this recognition builds
the sense of proportion that in turn
builds responsibility at the site of
conviction so here Weber is adapting one
of Nietzsche's signature moves in which
rejecting the disembodied conceits of
science and the absolutism of religion
alone allow us to approach the idea of
objectivity
for Nietzsche recall only perspectival
ISM permits the possibility of
interpretation beyond the interpreter
for Weber only recognized with the
foundation
- and the irreconcilability of ultimate
values retrieves them from nihilistic
devaluation from instrumentalization
from trivialization and hyper
politicization but the other way around
the ethic of responsibility in vapours
understanding entails acting without the
conceit that history and humanity have a
necessary or national natural shape or
ethical teleology or developed from pure
intention reason God or science the
ethic of responsibility entails
affirming politics as the domain where
value is imposed and transformed by the
context in which it's enacted rather
than a domain in which imminent or
divine value are realized both an ethic
of conviction and of ultimate ends
refuses this which is why both of them
are irresponsible that said favours
ethic makes an incredible demand on the
vanishing human soul that he thinks
nihilism produces the demand is that
wants to have unblinking consciousness
of the contingent nature of our passions
and dedicate ourselves to realizing them
this alone is how we mend the desire
that nihilism has broken it has nothing
to do with relativism subjectivism or
climbing empathy walls
rather it's an unprecedented
epistemological political consciousness
in which one knows one's values to be
situated partial temporal Geographic
located yet is no less committed to them
by virtue of that knowingness
appreciating the ethical irrationality
of political life formed by the tragedy
of action the unemancipated is in the
present and the permanent contest of
values in a secular order does something
else it brightens the light on immediate
political predicaments and possibilities
political dangers and political
openings these become more legible to
actors when they're not measured by
moral or behavioral logics the ethic
also aims to retrieve political life
from its overtaking by political
personality cults and a spirit of race
on tomorrow on one side and
bureaucratization and rationalization on
the other this in turn makes possible
bids for the future that are not rooted
in grievances against the past or the
present for the nihilistic absorption
with the personal and the immediate
finally this approach to political
renewal aims to recuperate freedom from
its destruction by rationalization and
by its nihilistic conversion into
irresponsible license weber defines
freedom mechanically as the absence of
constraint in his social science but in
his occasional writings and in the
vocational lectures weber says it is
with the soul that freedom is made that
is it's about enacting a life we've
chosen above all its living by the
lights of our own beliefs and that is
why he places a calling vocation finding
purpose and crafting a life and accord
with it at the very heart of freedom
nihilism generated by the expansion of
freedoms mechanical form extinguishes
its soulful form just as rationalization
usurps this kind of freedom with power
sorry justice rationalization usurped
this kind of freedom with power as power
independent of constraints building
economic and administrative systems that
invert freedom into its opposite more
than merely different the two forms of
freedom are thus mutually cancelling
freedom is unconstrained power built on
an order in which we are subjectively
and practically nearly bereft of the
freedom to craft ourselves and the world
according to values we affirm Labour's
bold bid in politics and
as a vocation man is to try to reverse
this in politics in foregrounding value
actualization as the essence of the
political vocation he aims to retrieve
freedom from the dual threat of its
domination by the machineries of capital
and administration on the one side and
the cheapness frivolity and indifference
to truth justice or Futurity of a
nihilistic age on the other if politics
is saturated with both indeed if favours
greatest dread was giant apparatuses of
domination wielded by vain demagogues it
is also where both could be countered
politics as a vocation is a vision for
working through nihilism by restoring
politics to its ancient function placing
at its heart a struggle over who we are
and what we should do it aims to make
politics redemptive after the death of
God not by purifying it of diabolical
powers or attempting to enshrine values
and institutions but by casting it as
the essential domain in which we decide
an assert value against the predicaments
for value that modernity has produced
it's where humans could become
responsible again not only for their own
actions but for the world in which this
capacity is imperiled by the powers that
we generate but which have slipped our
control if Faber was alert to the fate
prospects for this project
his antidote to despair was not hope but
great emotional spiritual political he
concludes the essay
only those with the staunch Ness of
heart that refuses to be daunted by the
collapse of all their hopes only those
whose spirit will not be broken if the
world proves too stupid or base to
accept what he wishes to offer and only
those who can still say nevertheless
despite everything only such a person as
the vocation for politics nevertheless
in spite of it all
these do not leap over the nihilistic
predicament but resist its world
eviscerating force with doggedness
dignity and responsible handling of
power in pursuit of a worldly cause we
could not be further from nature now two
points before we leave this for today
the first about culture the second about
education culture if values involve
complex regimes of attachment and desire
and nihilism represents a crisis of
desire failure to love this life in this
world this suggests the importance of
the left focusing on political culture
what cannot cling to belief that either
reason or interests will awaken those
lured and soothed by authoritarian
plutocrats we cannot expect to recruit
through rational argument or evidence
that a trump or a bull Cynara are
exploiting fears and resentments and
burning all of our children's future
rather our task is to Kindle desire for
a just livable sustainable world this is
a cultural project it's significant that
the rate has worked for decades at this
level in schools churches civic
associations media of course and more
the Left notwithstanding Gramsci Stewart
Hall or the program of the early
Frankfurt School not so much education
as nihilism depresses our value this
includes the value of truth and
facticity this is accelerated by the
powers of course of unaccountable media
both mass and social and by the
right-wing attack on higher education
and intellectualism more generally
combined these forces make the masses
both highly manipulable and undemocratic
and sensibility a condition that also
comports with the larger right wing
assault on democratic values
institutions and culture favor responded
to the crisis of liberalism in his time
by giving up on substantive democracy
investing all hope and responsible lead
[ __ ] however the wide moat that he built
between knowledge and politics which
we'll explore at some length tomorrow
deepened prospects for something else
irresponsible demagogues crassly preying
on fear suffering wounded supremacism
and scapegoating put another way in
confining knowledge to science and
politics to value Weber tore them apart
from one another and gave up on
educating for democracy as has much of
the West today one effect is popular
support for demagogues unchecked by
responsibility to truth constitutions
ecology regions world reversing this
rests in revaluing and reinvesting in
education for democracy on the one hand
and on the other orienting academic
knowledge pursuit and dissemination far
more closely to worldly ends than it has
known in recent decades this is what we
shall pursue tomorrow
[Music]